[SPEAKER_03]: Mesdames et messieurs, j'ai avec un réel plaisir et une reconnaissance envers tous les partenaires qui m'ont permis d'être là afin de présenter le résultat de notre travail sur les thèmes « Résilience économique en Afrique, le rôle de l'économisation d'État ».
[SPEAKER_00]: Je suis d'Irlande avant l'arrivée de Marélie, étudiante-chercheuse tchadienne à l'Université Développement au Cameroun,
[SPEAKER_00]: à la Faculté des sciences économiques et des gestions.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ce travail a été écrit avec la contribution du professeur Sonja Simon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Notre cadre de présentation s'organise autour de cinq points notamment quelques phrases stylisées, le problème, la méthodologie,
[SPEAKER_00]: des résultats et enfin quelques suggestions de politiques économiques.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dans un souci de contextualisation, trois clés majeures ont retenu notre association.
[SPEAKER_00]: Premièrement, la vulnérabilité des États africains face au choc.
[SPEAKER_00]: Comme vous pouvez le voir sur le graphique,
[SPEAKER_00]: La capacité de résistance et de reprise après les chocs des États africains est faible.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et cette capacité a connu son niveau le plus faible en 2019 et 2022, deux dates qui correspondent respectivement à la crise de Covid-19 de 2019 et la crise énergétique de 2022.
[SPEAKER_00]: Il faut savoir que la résilience est un concept emporté des physiques
[SPEAKER_00]: qui permet de caractériser des maladies.
[SPEAKER_00]: A l'heure actuelle, elle a plusieurs déclinaisons, notamment économiques, politiques, sociales, sécuritaires, entre autres.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mais à cause de l'occurrence des chocs économiques qui se sont succédés en Afrique, nous avons fait les choix de la résilience économique, qui a la capacité de maintenir la croissance à son point potentiel après les chocs,
[SPEAKER_00]: d'après les définitions de Duval et Degel en 2008.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merci.
[SPEAKER_00]: Le deuxième fait qui a retenu notre attention est la sous-représentation des femmes dans les différentes sphères économiques et politiques.
[SPEAKER_00]: Comme vous pouvez le voir sur les lieux graphiques, durant que l'autonomisation des femmes a connu une même amélioration, les femmes restent cependant sous-représentées dans les différentes sphères.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pourtant,
[SPEAKER_00]: Elle représente plus de la moitié de la population autonome africaine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mais, le troisième fait qui a retenu notre attention est la relation qui existe entre nos deux concepts.
[SPEAKER_00]: Qu'elle soit économique ou politique, l'autonomisation des femmes reste portée positivement à la résilience économique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mais, au but de l'économie,
[SPEAKER_00]: et notre thématique, nous n'avons pas seulement fait retour aux objectifs des différents organismes tels que les objectifs de développement durable de venue, l'agenda 163 de l'Union africaine, le PNUD, le CDE, mais également aux objectifs nationaux de développement tels que la SMD30 et le plan stratégique de développement du Tchad.
[SPEAKER_00]: qui méritèrent l'importance de la promotion de l'égalité des gens, mais également de la croissance économique inclusive et durable.
[SPEAKER_00]: Etant un travail scientifique, nous avons quand même passé des fondements théoriques et antérieurs, d'où le recours aux théories économiques telles que
[SPEAKER_00]: la théorie du capital du nord de Baker, la théorie de Keynes, la théorie féminine de Keynes, pour ne citer que ceux-ci.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pour ce qui concerne les fondements empiriques, bien que la santé de la génération empirique soit faible, elle nous a permis d'arroutir à des conditions assez intéressantes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Les effets de l'autonomisation des femmes sur la résilience économique sont non consensuels.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merci.
[SPEAKER_00]: Le problème économique, ici, concerne la sous-utilisation du potentiel des femmes et les conséquences de cette exclusion dans la capacité d'adaptation aux chocs et de résistance des états habitants.
[SPEAKER_00]: Selon Oliver de Vignancen, l'autonomisation des femmes est considérée comme un moteur stratégique de croissance inclusive, mais également un pilier
[SPEAKER_00]: de résistance au choc.
[SPEAKER_00]: Des analyses montrent également que sur les dates, genres et comblés, l'économie pourrait être boostée à au moins 7 milliards de dollars américains, permettant ainsi d'améliorer les conditions de vie des populations.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mesdames et Messieurs, la vulnérabilité des États africains, la sous-représentation des femmes dans les grandes sphères économiques et
[SPEAKER_00]: et la faiblesse de la littérature en hybride nous a amenés à poser la question suivante.
[SPEAKER_00]: Quels sont les effets de l'autonomisation des femmes sur la résilience économique en Afrique ?
[SPEAKER_00]: L'objectif donc de ce travail est d'analyser les effets de l'autonomisation des femmes sur la résilience économique en Afrique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Afin d'atteindre notre objectif et répondre à notre question de recherche, nous avons formulé deux hypothèses.
[SPEAKER_00]: La première,
[SPEAKER_00]: La colonisation des femmes améliore la résilience en Afrique.
[SPEAKER_00]: La deuxième, qu'est-ce que c'est que la colonisation des femmes transmise par le canal du capital humain et par le canal du développement financier ?
[SPEAKER_00]: Notre recherche est basée sur un échantillon de 48 pays africains, ce qui consiste sur la période 2000 à 2023.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ce choix est justifié non seulement par la disponibilité des données,
[SPEAKER_00]: mais également, par l'occurrence, des choses qui seront succédées en Afrique au cours de cette période.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nos données sont essentiellement secondaires et proviennent des sources et proviennent des institutions internationales telles que la Banque mondiale, le FMI, pour ne citer que celles-ci.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nos variables qui naissent sont la résilience économique, qui est tapée ici par l'indice de résistance et l'indice de reprise,
[SPEAKER_00]: l'autonomisation des femmes est classée par ses significateurs économiques et politiques et les deux canaux de transition, à savoir le développement financier et le capital humain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous estimons un modèle dynamique avec des variables de contrôle telles que le revenu,
[SPEAKER_00]: l'Internet, les investissements mondiaux et étrangers, les ressources naturelles, la densité économique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous estimons également un modèle de méditation qui nous permet d'analyser en effet les effets des canaux de transmission dans notre population.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pour analyser en effet les effets de l'autonomisation des femmes sur la résilience économique,
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous avons fait recours à la méthode des moments généralisés en systèmes et la méthode de Sorel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ce choix n'est pas anodin car cette technique permet de solutionner les problèmes fréquents liés aux données de Palmaire, notamment l'antigénéité, la tonalité inverse et l'évolution des variables inoxydables de l'occurrence dans le temps.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mesdames et messieurs,
[SPEAKER_00]: Après avoir estimé notre modèle, nous avons trouvé un résultat assez intéressant.
[SPEAKER_00]: L'autonomisation des femmes est positive et significative au seuil de 1%, peu importe les spécifications de notre modèle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et ces résultats sont les mêmes, peu importe l'indicateur de l'autonomisation considérée, c'est-à-dire l'autonomisation économique et l'autonomisation politique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merci.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ces résultats sont également robustes avec la prise en compte des variables institutionnelles telles que la stabilité politique et l'état de droit, mais également la prise en compte de la variable concurrente d'économie qui est l'indice de notre pays après l'échange.
[SPEAKER_00]: le test de médiation nous a permis de trouver des résultats assez intéressants également.
[SPEAKER_00]: L'autonomisation économique des femmes transite plus par le canal du capital humain que celui du développement financier, contrairement à l'autonomisation politique qui, elle, transite plus par le développement financier que le capital humain.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mesdames et Messieurs, renforcer le capital humain et améliorer l'accès au financement
[SPEAKER_00]: ne permet pas seulement d'atteindre un objectif de développement durable, celui de la promotion de l'égalité des genres, mais également d'améliorer la résilience économique en Afrique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ces résultats nous ont permis d'élaborer quelques suggestions de politiques économiques.
[SPEAKER_00]: Premièrement, construire les corridors en Afrique d'ici 2030
[SPEAKER_00]: afin de relier les régions enclavées aux régions désenclavées.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ceci permettra de réduire les coûts commerciaux et améliorer le taux de réponse aux crises.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bien précisément, les infrastructures, surtout routières, ne permettront pas non seulement d'améliorer le système de gestion de crise, mais également de renforcer la gouvernance des États africains.
[SPEAKER_00]: Deuxièmement,
[SPEAKER_00]: Créer des centres digitaux de financement et de formation dirigés par l'État dans les zones rurales dans chaque région de l'Afrique d'ici 2030.
[SPEAKER_00]: La formation en digital et en finance ne permettra pas seulement d'améliorer l'autonomisation économique des États, mais également leur économisation financière.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cela permettra aussi d'atteindre une croissance inclusive, ou du moins une croissance plus inclusive.
[SPEAKER_00]: Finalement, avoir un minimum de 30% de représentation des femmes dans les références décisionnelles locales et nationales.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cela permettra d'améliorer l'autonomisation politique des femmes en Afrique, mais également d'avoir des institutions plus inclusives d'ici 2030.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mesdames et Messieurs, l'autonomisation des femmes se révèle à la fin de cette étude comme une stratégie clé de renforcement et d'amélioration de la résilience économique en matière.
[SPEAKER_00]: Les chiffres le montrent, il ne reste plus qu'à agir.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merci pour votre attention et nous sommes ouverts à toutes questions et questions.
[SPEAKER_02]: de regarder un peu par quel biais est-ce que l'autonomisation des femmes appartient aux événements économiques, qui sont intéressés particulièrement aux événements financiers et aux prêts statuaires.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ça, c'est ça.
[SPEAKER_02]: En tout cas, c'est un angle qui rapporte quelque chose de nouveau, de parfait.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alors, pour être un peu plus précis, le concept de résilience, quand vous le décrivez, surtout en introduction, vous mélangez un petit peu le concept générique de résilience, qui est un concept multidimensionnel, qui doit avoir une étude politique, mais également économique, sociale, on parle aussi de résilience climatique, etc. et le concept de résilience économique.
[SPEAKER_02]: Donc on comprend bien dans votre partie en public que vous parlez de la résilience économique,
[SPEAKER_02]: c'est bien, mais je pense qu'il faudrait que vous clarifiez dès le début de quoi est-ce qu'on parle et pourquoi est-ce que vous vous intéressez à la résilience économique en particulier.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et je vais revenir dessus, mais je vais peut-être le mentionner maintenant.
[SPEAKER_02]: J'ai trouvé très intéressant que vous parliez également de la résilience climatique et une des choses que je pense qu'il faudrait alors ajouter à votre papier, c'est de voir le lien entre la résilience climatique et la résilience économique et voir comment est-ce que l'impact
[SPEAKER_02]: de l'autonomisation des femmes va affecter ces deux résidences marocaines et musulmanes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Parce qu'on sait que la résidence climatique, ou l'absence de résidence climatique d'ailleurs, la fragilité, on va dire, tout ce qui concerne le changement climatique, les catastrophes naturels, a un impact marco-économique, notamment sur les musulmans.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et ça, je trouve que ce serait vraiment une nouveauté.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et pourquoi je mentionne ces cas-ci ?
[SPEAKER_02]: C'est parce que
[SPEAKER_02]: Je trouve que vous n'insistez pas assez sur la valeur appliquée de votre santé.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et ça, c'est un commentaire que j'ai publié, d'autres papiers également.
[SPEAKER_02]: Je trouve que quand vous décrivez votre problème de recherche, vous n'insistez pas assez sur ce que vous apportez à la littérature.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pourquoi est-ce que c'est important que vous vous intéressez à la question à laquelle vous vous intéressez ?
[SPEAKER_02]: Et ça, c'est très important.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et je pense que le papier peut prendre un angle intéressant.
[SPEAKER_02]: On regarde dans un proposant conjointement ces deux types de résignances-là.
[SPEAKER_02]: et voir maintenant l'effet de l'autorégulation des familles sur ces résidences.
[SPEAKER_02]: Donc je ne reviendrai pas là-dessus plus tard.
[SPEAKER_02]: C'est un commentaire que j'avais sur la partie anglais.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alors, l'autre point que j'avais, dont il est mentionné, c'est que la valeur a été identifiée clairement, ce que vous apportez.
[SPEAKER_02]: J'ai également un point sur la mesure que vous avez de la résidence économique.
[SPEAKER_02]: Vous n'en avez pas parlé dans votre communication,
[SPEAKER_02]: Mais vous regardez un index, vous appelez ça « Recorded Index » et « Evidence Index » et dans votre partie en public, vous réglez aussi des index sur des index.
[SPEAKER_02]: Donc déjà là, on vous dit comment est-ce que vous allez accepter votre condition.
[SPEAKER_02]: Voilà, il faudrait peut-être clarifier un peu ce que vous faites en tout cas.
[SPEAKER_02]: J'ai l'impression que c'est un peu une boîte noire.
[SPEAKER_02]: On a des index comme variable intégrée, des index comme variable expliquée.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et ce qu'on obtient, à part le signe que vous pouvez interpréter, qu'est-ce que ça nous dit en termes d'amplitude, par exemple ?
[SPEAKER_02]: Comment est-ce que tu vas interpréter votre coefficient ?
[SPEAKER_02]: Faites attention, en tout cas, en termes de météorologie.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et justement, je voulais proposer de regarder, soit comme test de recrutement, mais notamment dans votre estimation principale des mesures alternatives,
[SPEAKER_02]: Pourquoi ne pas juste partir sur les variables de stabilité macroéconomique standard pour commencer par ça déjà ?
[SPEAKER_02]: Le debt-to-division ratio, le fiscal deficit-to-division ratio, les répartitions de chômage.
[SPEAKER_02]: C'est quelque chose de très simple qu'on a tous envie de comprendre avant d'aller visiter un peu la vie avec des index.
[SPEAKER_02]: On ne sait pas trop ce qu'il y a dedans, on ne sait pas trop comment on les a calculés.
[SPEAKER_02]: et voir un peu déjà avec ces variables-là, on sait comment ça va se passer au cours des années.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et peut-être qu'on va étudier l'analyse par la suite.
[SPEAKER_02]: Donc ça, c'est une chance que vous gagnerez en précision.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et vous pourrez utiliser peut-être même un peu plus, une fois que vous aurez obtenu un coefficient avec ces variables-là, ce que ça veut dire en termes de magnitude et d'ampleur.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sur l'analyse sur les canaux de transmission, je pense qu'il faudrait approfondir un peu.
[SPEAKER_02]: Quand vous avez commencé par me dire que dans la littérature, on s'intéressait aux développements financiers, au capital humain, mais aussi aux technologies d'information et de communication.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et je ne sais pas pourquoi vous n'avez pas testé vos résultats avec les ICT par exemple, je ne sais pas si vous le savez.
[SPEAKER_02]: Parce que les données existent, je vous donnerai le lien, mais des données très récentes, qui vont de 2005 à 2025, si je ne me trompe pas, avec des désagrégations entre l'Union Européenne et l'Union Européenne, avec la part de l'administration qui a accès par exemple à Internet, ou qui a accès à des réseaux sociaux, avec quelques pays, alors, ça qui est sur le marché, c'est quelques pays qui ont des désagrégations par exemple,
[SPEAKER_02]: Et moi, je serais très intéressée de voir également si on parle de publicisation et on sait que de plus en plus, notamment, je pense aux femmes qui sont dans les... qui sont dans les petits visuels, avec le mobile money, par exemple.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ils ont beaucoup de choses avec le mobile money.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et ça, moi, je serais très intéressée de voir vos résultats en regardant les résultats que vous avez là, qui existent à peu près tous les trois pays.
[SPEAKER_02]: faire le but d'un autre pâté, parce que ça va faire beaucoup pour un seul pâté, mais just feel it at once, et ça va enrichir le pâté, et ça vous permettra aussi de dire beaucoup de choses.
[SPEAKER_02]: Justement, tous ces télésystèmes de femmes, je sais que beaucoup de femmes, notamment en Afrique, sont dans les petits business, et pour ces femmes-là, de plus en plus, l'accès aux pylônes, par exemple, les technologies d'information et de communication en général, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alors, je pense que ce sera peut-être au lieu d'un autre papier, le papier du professeur.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alors, sur le JPM Estimates, je pense que ça ne devrait pas être l'estimation principale.
[SPEAKER_02]: À mon sens, peut-être que vous pouvez garder ça, et j'arrive à ce que ce soit en réalité, vous pouvez garder ça comme une campagne de modestesse, mais encore une fois, c'est plus dans l'esprit de commencer par ce qui est le plus simple.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et maintenant, vous nous amenez vers l'université de l'université de l'université de l'université de l'université de l'université de l'université de l'université de l'université de l'université de l'université
[SPEAKER_02]: la crise de 2008, etc. Peut-être approfondissez un petit peu plus en retirant les years which were fixed et en mettant les années de crise spécifiquement.
[SPEAKER_02]: C'est déjà capturé, quand vous êtes dans les years which were fixed, mais quand vous vous intéressez à la résidence en particulier, vous pouvez retirer les années et mettez juste 2008, où on a eu la crise de 2008, 2019 pour Covid, etc. Et là, comment on peut vraiment nous dire l'impact sur la résidence ?
[SPEAKER_02]: Parce que là, on identifie
[SPEAKER_02]: Oui, un autre point, je pense que je vais passer 4 minutes, mais là, dans la version de votre papier,
[SPEAKER_02]: En utilisant les index de recovery et de résilience, vous tenez l'impression que tous les chocs auxquels on a affaire sont des chocs économiques.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or, on l'a vu dans le passé précédent, on peut avoir des chocs géopolitiques qui ne sont pas économiques, mais qui ont des impacts extrêmement importants sur le système économique, avec des impacts sur les institutions économiques, avec la crise de la frustration sociale.
[SPEAKER_02]: Donc, je pense qu'il faudrait quand même faire cette distinction-là entre les chocs économiques et les chocs qui sont a priori géopolitiques, mais avec des forts impacts économiques dans votre analyse.
[SPEAKER_02]: Donc, je pense que, en tout cas, c'est des nuances, au minimum, si vous ne pouvez peut-être pas les tester, au minimum, vous pouvez les discuter et discuter comment est-ce que ça affecte vos résultats.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et est-ce que l'autonomisation des femmes va avoir cet effet ?
[SPEAKER_02]: selon le type de choc que l'on a.
[SPEAKER_02]: Peut-être que ça, ça marche, ça n'a pas d'importance, mais ce serait intéressant de le comprendre.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oui, alors un autre point, j'étais un peu confus sur vos indicateurs de gouvernance, parce que ces indicateurs de gouvernance-là, pour nous, ça n'a pas fait en sorte qu'il y a beaucoup de choses dans votre parcours, mais parce que ça peut être des apports variables, mais ça peut aussi être des moyens de contrôle, comme ça peut être des candidats
[SPEAKER_02]: on pourrait se dire que l'autonomisation des femmes aura un impact peut-être plus ou moins important selon le niveau de la qualité des institutions dans le pays.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et à ce moment-là, ce n'est pas tout à fait ce que vous faites.
[SPEAKER_02]: À ce moment-là, ce serait peut-être intéressant d'organiser ça dans une situation de migration, plutôt que d'en faire une barrière de concret ou classique.
[SPEAKER_02]: parce qu'ils pensent que la qualité institutionnelle est extrêmement importante.
[SPEAKER_02]: Déjà, évidemment, vous allez avoir plein de problèmes d'ordigénéité, parce que la qualité institutionnelle va aussi déterminer si les femmes sont plus obtenantes dans un pays.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mais en tout cas, en termes de corrélation juste, en termes d'analyse descriptive, ce serait intéressant de changer de langue par laquelle vous regardez les indicateurs de gouvernance, et plutôt de voir ça dans un grand camp.
[SPEAKER_02]: Est-ce que c'est un aimable ?
[SPEAKER_02]: Est-ce que ça permet ?
[SPEAKER_02]: à l'autonomisation des femmes, d'avoir plus ou moins d'impact sur la résilience économique ou pas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Et ça vous permettra aussi de peut-être plus ajuster vos recommandations de politique économique, parce que les recommandations, alors certaines viennent des résultats que vous montrez, mais elles sont un peu décorrélées de vos résultats et de votre...
[SPEAKER_02]: Je pense que vous pouvez y penser.
Merci beaucoup.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merci pour toutes vos suggestions et vos remarques.
[SPEAKER_03]: C'est assez nombreux.
[SPEAKER_03]: Mais ce que je voulais dire, c'est
[SPEAKER_03]: Il y a des normes que je fais, que je n'ai pas réellement pensées, et vous venez de me donner des points de recherche assez intéressants pour améliorer ce travail.
[SPEAKER_03]: Comme vous pouvez le voir, le travail n'est pas encore terminé, comme tout le monde scientifique.
[SPEAKER_03]: On va prendre encore vos recommandations et essayer d'améliorer ce travail pour qu'il puisse contribuer aux sciences sociales de façon générale.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merci.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merci beaucoup.
[SPEAKER_04]: Je m'appelle Francis Lenianguyo.
[SPEAKER_04]: Je viens du département de recherche de l'EPA.
[SPEAKER_04]: Mes questions sont liées aux suggestions de l'EPA.
[SPEAKER_04]: D'abord, j'aimerais apprécier la fierté dans les suggestions.
[SPEAKER_04]: Et puis, je pense qu'il y a encore un peu de choses à faire.
[SPEAKER_04]: Qu'informent ces dates de recherche ?
[SPEAKER_04]: en 2030, 2035, 30% des femmes, comment arrivez-vous à ces timelines spécifiques et ces objectifs que je ne vois pas dans les réseaux?
[SPEAKER_04]: Merci.
[SPEAKER_05]: Je suis le docteur Akwala, conseiller économique à l'Après-Mathieu, en revanche.
[SPEAKER_05]: Je souhaiterais tout d'abord féliciter Madame pour cette excellente présentation.
[SPEAKER_05]: Je souhaiterais savoir par quelles variables attend capter le développement financier.
[SPEAKER_05]: Parce que le développement financier est multidimensionnel.
[SPEAKER_05]: Dans le cas de votre sujet,
[SPEAKER_05]: qui parle de l'autonomisation de la femme, et je pense qu'il peut s'impliquer sur les tables de parler de l'inclusion financière.
[SPEAKER_05]: Parce que le développement financier est une variable qui est très macro, englobe le développement des institutions, englobe également le développement du marché financier, avec un accent particulier sur la profondeur, un accent particulier sur la résilience, un accent particulier sur l'accès.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mais dans le cas de votre travaux, je pense que c'est une suggestion.
[SPEAKER_05]: Il était plus solvable de parler des éclusions financières, qui a plus un lien direct avec l'économie, avec l'économisation, plus de développement des acteurs économiques, de parler du développement financier qui, à mon sens, est un peu plus global.
[SPEAKER_04]: C'est un sujet très intéressant.
[SPEAKER_04]: Je m'appelle Topher Flash, je suis conseiller spécialisé dans les affaires économiques.
[SPEAKER_04]: Je voudrais juste faire quelques observations.
[SPEAKER_04]: Je crois que vous avez mentionné une addition de 7 trillions à la GDP globale, 7 trillions d'euros, si cela peut être fait.
[SPEAKER_04]: J'espère que cela s'adapte aux femmes africaines, parce que la GDP globale est actuellement entre 100 et 120 trillions.
[SPEAKER_04]: Donc, et encore une fois, le sujet ressemble beaucoup à une discussion des années 1970-1980.
[SPEAKER_04]: J'espère que nous pouvons nous amener vers l'idée des hommes et des femmes, parce qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui nous ont élevés.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nous vivons dans une époque AI, le monde est confronté à de sérieux défis en termes d'emploi, et plus de 200 000-300 000 travailleurs,
[SPEAKER_04]: qui a été créée par l'entreprise Gozaru Tech dans les dernières deux mois, qui est une menace claire pour tout le monde, peut-être parce qu'ils ont cité l'efficacité de l'AI.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cependant, notez aussi que l'Afrique a encore une grande économie informelle, peut-être que 60% de notre GDP est informée.
[SPEAKER_04]: Et dans le secteur informatique, les femmes dominent.
[SPEAKER_04]: Et regardez autour de la rue, il y a une très bonne représentation des femmes dans ce hall.
[SPEAKER_04]: même si ce n'est pas la première présentation de la haute étoile.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ma propre expérience est que les femmes sont à la haute étoile, et nous sommes fiers d'eux, et elles le font de manière incroyable.
[SPEAKER_04]: En fait, dans certains états, comme au Nigeria, nous devons convaincre les femmes de permettre à certains hommes d'être dans l'espace.
[SPEAKER_04]: Je pense donc que nous devons penser à l'idée que, sauf pour les états politiques, qui sont toujours développés, mais nous voyons un pays comme le Rwanda, comme l'Éthiopie,
[SPEAKER_04]: qui ont donné aux femmes une très bonne représentation dans le Parlement et qui ont encouragé les femmes à faire des choses.
[SPEAKER_04]: Je voudrais juste, au cours du temps, refaire le sujet au-delà de l'idée primitive que les hommes doivent empêcher les femmes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nous devons tous empêcher nous-mêmes et les femmes font beaucoup de bien.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merci beaucoup.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merci.
[SPEAKER_01]: J'aimerais parler de ce que vous avez dit.
[SPEAKER_01]: J'apprécie votre présentation.
[SPEAKER_01]: C'est un très bon insight pour moi et je vais l'utiliser pour que l'IH puisse vous l'envoyer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Quand j'ai écrit une petite pièce sur l'économie de l'homme en 2005, j'étais en train de travailler au Centre de l'économie de l'Inde.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que depuis lors, j'ai été mentorée et
[SPEAKER_01]: Je ne suis pas sûre que nous pourrions utiliser le mot « puissance » parce qu'on dénonce qui est puissant et qui n'est pas puissant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Et je pense que le temps est venu au point où nous devons réellement le déterminer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Et je ne veux pas dire que nous pouvons scientifiquement le déterminer.
[SPEAKER_01]: C'est plus une observation et je ne dis pas que je suis désagréable avec le fait que vous m'avez exprimé
[SPEAKER_01]: mais je pense qu'il y a une connotation de « tu es plus puissant que moi, donc je vais t'empowerer ».
[SPEAKER_01]: Il doit y avoir des gens qui peuvent arriver avec une façon plus inclusive, significative et non divisible de partager ce qu'on est en tant qu'humain, en tant que partie de la société, en tant qu'attaque intérieure de la société.
[SPEAKER_01]: La dernière chose que je voudrais mentionner, c'est quelque chose qui est très difficile de faire, mais c'est une très bonne question.
[SPEAKER_01]: Vous avez mentionné les différents chocs.
[SPEAKER_01]: J'aimerais aussi vous parler des chocs, si vous ne l'avez pas déjà fait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Il y a le choc culturel, il y a le choc personnel, il y a tout ce genre de choses que les femmes font.
[SPEAKER_01]: J'aimerais voir des gens qui font tous les différents chocs que les femmes ont expérimentés dans la nuit, mais aussi dans la nuit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Je pense que...
[SPEAKER_05]: Il y a de nombreuses pratiques actuelles aujourd'hui qui sont en train de se produire dans le secteur de l'innovation.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ce que vous étudiez a vraiment pris ça en compte.
[SPEAKER_05]: Vous allez dans les indicateurs complexes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Et je pense que, avant d'aller à l'estimation avec les indicateurs complexes, vous devez prendre en compte quelques indicateurs très simples qui sont déjà disponibles.
[SPEAKER_05]: pour aussi capturer des femmes en vulnérabilité.
[SPEAKER_05]: On peut parler, par exemple, des femmes dans des emplois libéraux.
[SPEAKER_05]: C'est aussi un élément de travail qui est très important.
[SPEAKER_05]: Il y a aussi des femmes dans l'agriculture.
[SPEAKER_05]: On va essayer de voir comment cela contribue à l'économie du pays.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ok, merci.
[SPEAKER_05]: Merci beaucoup pour votre présentation.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alors moi, je voulais demander, est-ce que, puisqu'on a parlé de votre papier, est-ce que vos papiers abordent l'aspect de papier contacté ?
[SPEAKER_04]: Parce qu'on sait que 30% des pays adoptés, 30% des contacts de l'État, dans vos pays de charte, est-ce que l'aspect apprécié parle de cet aspect ?
[SPEAKER_04]: Parce que si l'aspect de papier n'est pas accepté, on va savoir pourquoi.
[SPEAKER_04]: C'est-à-dire, est-ce que votre papier aborde l'aspect de côté dessous ?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oui, c'est focalisé sur l'économie de France.
[SPEAKER_04]: Est-ce que votre avis aborde cet aspect ?
[SPEAKER_04]: Merci beaucoup.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merci pour vos questions et suggestions.
[SPEAKER_03]: Je reviens sur la question de l'emploi temporaire, si j'ai bien compris.
[SPEAKER_03]: Donc, quand le problème couvre 2000 à 2023, nous avons utilisé les données de la banque en 2024.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nous, dans la présentation, on a mis le VDI entre 41 et 2024, parce qu'on l'utilisait en 2024.
[SPEAKER_03]: les données de l'offre temporelle, qui était 2000 à 2023.
[SPEAKER_03]: La dernière question, concernant les 30% de quotas.
[SPEAKER_03]: Il y a en fait des 30% de quotas.
[SPEAKER_03]: C'est vrai que les pays ont adopté, certains pays ont adopté les 30% de quotas, mais elle n'est pas effective.
[SPEAKER_03]: C'est pourquoi nos littéraires ont dit que l'effectivité de la représentation de minimum 30% dans les états
[SPEAKER_03]: décisionnelle.
[SPEAKER_03]: On en parle en militaires, on en dit des choses, mais elle n'est pas exécutive.
[SPEAKER_03]: Et surtout dans mon pays de Tchad, c'est un manque très... un manque important.
[SPEAKER_03]: Et bon, concernant votre seconde question, nous n'avons pas abordé
[SPEAKER_03]: le côté économie des soins n'a rien d'important et nous allons voir dans quelle mesure il est intégré dans son travail et dans l'analyse pour améliorer le travail.
[SPEAKER_03]: Et en ce qui concerne les autres questions et suggestions,
[SPEAKER_03]: Nous avons pris en compte toutes vos questions, toutes vos suggestions, surtout dans la mesure des indicateurs d'autonomisation et même du terme d'autonomisation des femmes, ce qui pose un peu un réel problème, parce qu'à l'heure actuelle, quand on parle d'autonomisation des femmes, on va juste voir la femme qui est plus supérieure à l'homme, alors qu'il est à savoir des questions de ça, il est question des droits, des libertés et d'opportunité des femmes.
[SPEAKER_03]: C'est de ça qu'il est question, même comme vous l'avez dit,
[SPEAKER_03]: et suggérer nos valeurs, faire plus attention à ce qui concerne les termes et intégrer cela pour la raison du possible dans notre travail.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merci à nous.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merci.